The last sweater that I had has been
something that I'm wearing is something
that's been in my brain for ever.
And I've wanted to do
something with this cowl look
without a whole lot of muss and fuss.
And I saw a hand knitting
pattern that was like this.
And
being a hand knitter, you know,
they were able to OK, let's just say
this is the original pattern, right?
They were able to do increases, increase,
increase, increase, increase, increase,
increase, increase. To get this extra
fabric right here at the neckline.
Well, you know, I'll be darned.
I'm not going to be moving
50 stitches every row on both
sides and doing all those.
So what I did was
and there's no boo boos on this one.
Let me get let me show you
what I did with this one.
So I took my basic basic sweater.
Same same thing, no sleeves,
and I did the increases
at the sleeve edge.
I had enough stitches.
So this is the back, knit the back,
just the way the pattern said,
put in some markers for the neck opening
and then just knit increases at the armholes.
So that when I brought those shoulders up.
So there's increases all along here.
So when I brought the shoulders up,
matched it with the back, I got the extra.
Now I really, really, really like the way
this lays, especially for a summer job.
But I think, you know,
I really could do it for anything.
I've also seen cowls done
where you knit a V-neck.
So I would have knit shaped my sweater
here and then added an extra piece.
But, boy, that just seemed
like a lot of extra work.
So this is just one of those has
been in my mind for a while.
I wanted to share with you crochet
around the edges, no side slits.
I wasn't going to go there.